in the new game Assassin's Creed Mirage
you will encounter the character H the
translator this is in fact HB isak one
of the most important and significant
Scholars of that era and perhaps of all
time playing a major role in the
transmission and survival of Science and
philosophy H IB isak was an Arab scholar
translator and scientist originally from
Ala close to the city of kufa he and his
family were Christian specifically
following what is known as nistoran
Christianity but grew up and lived in
the heartland of the Muslim Abbasid
caliphate hunain became a greatly
learned man among other things being
able to speak and read not only Arabic
but also Syriac and Greek which would
become very useful later on eventually
he found himself in Bagdad during the
height of the Abbasid caliphate what is
sometimes referred to as the so-call
golden age of Islam the Abbasid cffs at
that time were great sponsors and
patrons of scientific and philosophical
advancement the prophet Muhammad is
thought to have encouraged his community
the Muslims to quote seek knowledge even
if you have to go to China and the early
Muslim Community really took this
message to Heart during the 9th century
the abbasids established a so-called B
hikma the House of Wisdom as a great
library and Center for scholarly
activity similar to other institutions
like the ancient Library of Alexandria
the House of Wisdom stored and gathered
many books on all kinds of topics from
around the world and in connection with
this was started what is known as the
translation movement where in order to
further knowledge and wisdom old
philosophical and scientific texts from
Greece India and Persia were translated
into Arabic and made them accessible to
a new audience and Herb isak became
perhaps the most significant and
successful of all of these translators
together with his son ISB H and other
associates H painstakingly translated
all kinds of text medical text by galin
and hypocrates philosophical cheeses by
Aristotle and Plato and many more he
followed an earlier group of translators
also connected to the House of Wisdom
led by the Muslim Arab philosopher
alindi but the translations of herine
and his group were Superior in most ways
setting a high standard going forward
heran would often translate from Greek
into Syriac and then they would
translate from syak into Arabic and they
used a methodology that was in general
very very successful the translation
movement and the work of Han among
others became a decisive factor for
continuing the transmission of
scientific knowledge into the Islamic
world and allowed future thinkers to
build and carry on that Legacy there is
no IB CA or IB rush abisa or aoiz
without the works of these translators
which of course has significant Ripple
effects for the rest of the world too
indeed it is through the works of the
Muslim and Islamic HTE thinkers that
much of this knowledge and wisdom
survived until today not only remaining
an important factor in the intellectual
world of the Middle East but also
eventually making its way into Europe
and having massive effects on figures
and movements there that would of course
lead to Great advancement in scientific
and philosophical thinking in other
words if it wasn't for Han isak and that
was associated with him in 9th century
Bagdad the modern world with its
scientific advancements probably
wouldn't be what it is today and it
really highlights the incredible
intellectual environment that was Bagdad
during the golden days of the abased
caliphate where the seeking of wisdom
and knowledge was highly valued not only
for its own sake but also for the
benefit of and in connection to religion
and the fact that her name was a
Christian is also a good indicator of
this environment where the Quest for
knowledge was a joint effort regardless
of religious affiliation it's really
heartening to see such an important yet
sadly little alone character portrayed
in a popular video game it shows a dedic
ation to historical accuracy and
representation that I have come to
expect from this franchise and will
hopefully lead more people to discover
and learn about these amazing and
important
[Music]
figures